R RYAN NOBLES  JOININGEEN.
REPRESENTATIVE GREEN JUST SPOKE
COMMES  A THI
LEF WEEKS AGO WHERE SHE
COMPARED THE MASNDATES IN
THE HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES TO
THNNINGSHOLOCAT.EEWAY CRITICIZER
THOSE E ACTUALLY DOUBLED DOWN O
INTERVIEWS AFTER THE FACT, BUT
TODAY  AN ABRUPT TURN OF
E SAID SHE VISITHOCA
WASHINGTON, D.C. AND THOCOMMENT.
TAKE A LISTEN E OF WHAT D TO TO
E MADE A MISTAKE AND
IT'S REALLE FOR A
COUPLE OF WEEKS NOW, SO I DEFIN.
TH SOME PEOPLE DON'T
PEOPLE DENY, THERE INO MPARISON
THERE ARE WORDS I HAVE SAID D M.
FOR THAT, I WANTO APOGIZE.IS TRE
I SAW THAT TODAY AE
HOLOCAUST UM THINKHAT WE SHOULD
SORRY FOR OFFENDING PELES ABOUE
SURPRISE UNDERSTATEMENT.
GREEN HAS MADE HER MAR
T TIME IN CONGRESS AS BEING
SO APOLOGIZES
DOWN AND DEFENDS HER
CONTROVERSIAREMARKS.
SHLY WITHDREE  POINT O WHILE
COMMEN COMPARING MASK MANDATES
TO THE, SHE DIDN'T GO
AS FAR AS TO TAKBA SOME OF
WAS PRESSED ON COVER  SHE'S SAI.
MODERN DEMOCRATIRT THE
NAZI PARTY.
WE ALSO PRESSED HER ON FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S COMMENTS WHERE
STED THERE WERE GOOD
PEOPLE ON BOTH
CONDEMN THE
REMARKS.
I ASKED R SPECIFICBOUTF  ANDRENE
N FOLLOWERS, A
TIME WASIATED ID HADO T K ABOUT.
>> AS FAR ASHAS NED,
GLO YOU MAKEIS
OG MARJORIE TAYLEEN?HAT WE S TOS
SNUS TO.SHE WAEAY SCHOEDME
AWARE E MADE THOSEBE SHE WAS.'
I INK SHE'S DEE, HER
LEADER IN CONGRESS AND OER
REPUBLICANS AROU COUNTRY
TO R S
WEL HAVEO SEE
SHE BEHAVD FUTURE.IT WAS CLEARST
UNTIE WALKED
.SLOFOR ME TO BELIEVE
S?
IT COULD BE TRUE.
SHG A
DIFFERENT TUNE TODAY
>> IT'T LIKE THIS WAS
ONE-OFF FROM HER.BL DRD I TO BE
APOLOGY IS GE'LL HAVE TOK THERE.
I D TO
DO THID I THING TO THE
MUSEUM WAS A GOOD IDEA
BUT WE'LHAVE TSELO
GES TO FOLLOW HEAND WHETHER SH
SAY, YOU KNO AGR
MARM
MARJGREEN INHO
MAYBE WE TOO OUGHT TO R WORD SH
SOND HOW RINUPTO
LONG THEY LASTNDCOME
NEXT.
>> RYAN, HAS THERE BEEN AN
REACTION SO FA HILL?
NED A VE
TIME AGOND THIS PRESS CONFERE
OF IT ONLY
ABOUT LF HOUR BEFORE SHE
AP THEMICROPHONE.
PARTICULARRKS. AHANCE ETONSE FMW
WESSEDUT THAT.
HOW COULD YOU NOT UNRSHE
HER.SH EVESIE ITZ CONCENTRATN P
WHEN SHE WAS 19 YEAROLS AWARE J
THAT PERIOD OF TIME WAS.
E EX SHES SHE WAS
NCE SLOW CREEP ID  THAT SHE THOS
NOW MAKING THA WAS A
BADECISION.
TIME DURIN
PRES
ABOUNGRESSWOMAN ILHAN OMAR  ANDA
ISRAELI O HAMAS S. GOVERNMENT
AND THE JUMPEDN ATTACKING
CONGRESSWOMAOMAR.
MADE ITLE  BM E  F THE ME THINS
GOING TOIG FOR.AT INCLUDES A LO
FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> Y THIS CLIP OFT
MARJORIEID LASH ABOUT THE HOLOCN
DY TREATED LIKE  WHERE PEOPLEE
SECOND CLASS CITIZENS, SO MUCH
ABUSE THAN G OULYE --
>> THEN SH ON TH TWEET AEWS LAT
>> YES, SHE
TL OE THATNCY PELOSI IG OU
IT W RIDICULOUS AN
IN SOME JEOPARDY.R THIS.E WAS PH
I , LEADERS WERENG
AWAY FROM R SAYI
REEIR WORDS.
K PRIVATELROBABL
NEEDED TO GET
THERE.
AS RYA OUT, THE
NTRITE.
W
BUT I THINK WE HAVE TOENFRN.
I HES HAVE MEANING
VERY OFFENSIVE TO AN AWFUL LOT .
AGT WONDER SCOTA
A TOURF E
HOLOCAUSSEN SHOULD TAK O HANWASI
MBOUSE
MOBLIC